JAKE ARCHIBALD: So fans
of the old Android browser
will be disappointed
to hear that it's not
in the latest version
of Android anymore.
The Chrome is--
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, great.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
The default browser
is now Chrome in 4.4.
But not only that,
but the WebView
that's used by native
applications-- that's
now Chrome, as well.
So you can make native
applications using
a mixture of the best
of native and mix that
with the best of the web.
But what is the
best way to do that?
And the answers, I
believe, are going
to vomit out of the mouth
of our next speaker.
Are you ready to go?
MATT GAUNT: I hope so, yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
OK.
Welcome our next speaker.
It's Matt Gaunt!
[APPLAUSE]
MATT GAUNT: Thank you, everyone.
Wow.
What an entrance into a talk--
vomiting out of my mouth.
Thank you, Jake.
So yeah, this session
is going to be
about building mobile apps with
the brand-new Chrome WebView.
My name is Matthew Gaunt.
If my clicker would
work-- there we go.
I'm a developer advocate
from the London office.
Generally, there
seems to be this trend
of having stupid
photos of yourself.
If you've ever seen
Paul Kinlan or Paul
Lewis doing a
presentation-- yeah.
I don't know what this face is.
I wish it didn't exist.
So I have to publicize
it, apparently.
Before I start giving this talk,
I have to give a disclaimer.
I feel like the minute
you start talking
about bringing web technologies
into a native stack,
there's instantly
kind of a flame war.
I don't want to go into that.
But ultimately, I am
a native developer.
Before I joined Google, I
largely focused on Android.
But I did iOS, BlackBerry,
Nokia [? Cube ?].
And towards kind of the end when
I was working at that company,
we were doing a lot of stuff
with bringing web technologies
into our native apps.
We were using JavaScript
as the back end.
And then as we started
moving more and more forward,
we kind of got to this
point where some companies--
they couldn't do native
apps, things like gambling.
You're not allowed in the
apps stores with that.
And our designers were kind
of excited by this point
because at that point it was
like, well, cool, HTML5, CSS3.
This is awesome.
And seeing them, where they've
had years of experience doing
[? Jatomi ?] and all
these different apps,
they just ran with
HTML5 and CSS3.
And for me, I loved
what they were doing.
The biggest problem that
I had was it's just like,
well, you're still in the web.
If you want a presence
in the app store--
which many people
did-- how do you
bring this web
stack into an app?
Because normally, the WebViews,
they kind of are a bit rubbish.
And that's why I
was really excited,
because if you didn't hear-- and
Jake's kind of announced it--
we actually swapped out the
Android WebView with the Chrome
WebView.
So we've got M30 now in
KitKat, which is awesome.
It means that we get this kind
of slightly disappointing score
of 284, and it gets bumped
up to 424, which is awesome.
And it's not just
the fact that we
get HTML5 and CSS3 features
that we didn't have before.
We've also got the
V8 JavaScript engine,
which is much faster
than the older WebView.
But even the more
important thing
is going to be the DevTools
that you will know and love.
One of the questions
I always get
is features that kind
of come with this.
So it means you get indexedDB,
request animation frame--
insanely important when it comes
to performance-- SVG filters
and effects.
Jake Archibald has done a
fantastic blog post on SVGs,
and I've seen a number
of things come out
of it that are awesome.
Web sockets-- you may not
really think about this,
but I love this for live
reload, like insanely, a lot.
And then there's more, but I'm
not going to talk about them.
So for me, when it comes
to developing mobile web
apps using the WebView,
it kind of comes down
to three different things.
There's the workflow,
which for me
is really different between
native and web apps.
I'm going to go
into it in a minute.
Native features, that's
probably one of the main reasons
why you're using the
WebView in an app,
is because you want
access to something more.
And then you've got,
obviously, the design.
I don't know if
any of you guys had
some of the really
early Android devices.
But if you saw the design
of some of those apps,
they were kind of cringy.
And I think one of the
major things that most
of the mobile
platforms have done
is they've done
design guidelines.
And the developers have gone,
OK, cool, I'll follow these
and produced beautiful apps.
So how does that apply
in this scenario?
So let's start with workflow.
Generally, if you see a
native developer coding,
they will do this cycle.
Code, compile, repeat.
You can arguably say
that we all do the same.
In the very, very early
days, where we'd sit there,
we'd write some
code in HTML CSS.
We go to our
browser, hit refresh.
And that's our first
web page, done.
But in the web, we
have live reload.
And it's insanely helpful
because you just sit there.
You code away, hit Save,
and then you're done.
You just watch the effects
just happen before you.
So who here is
familiar with Gradle?
Not Gradle, Grunt.
Start with Grunt.
OK.
So about 50%.
So Grunt is a
JavaScript task runner.
So you can basically pull
in third-party modules that
basically will perform
some action for you.
So you can imagine
you want something
where when you say,
start my server,
it will just start
the server for you.
It will compile your SAS.
It will minify your
JavaScript, your HTML,
and just basically take care of
a lot of housekeeping for you.
So when you come to
native, at the moment,
we've got Gradle, which is
new in the Android Studio.
And Gradle is kind of
similar in many respects.
You pull in plug-ins that
do a particular task.
So one of the things
that I wanted to do
was join these two
things together.
I didn't want to have
to sit there and have
different workflows.
I didn't want to compile and
wait for this stuff to happen.
So with the new WebView, we can
actually get a nice flow going.
So if I show you
what we've got-- so
I'll get away from this.
Oh, stop it.
There we go.
So this is a
standard build file.
So we've got things like
just the Android task, which
the Android team
have put together.
And basically, that is
your Android build step.
Now you might
notice down here, we
have this notion
of product flavors.
Now the way you can think
of product flavors--
the canonical example is someone
has a free and a paid app.
Free app might pull in adverts.
The paid one, you
don't get them.
In this scenario,
well, I want one
that is going to
be a static build.
I want all the HTML, JavaScript,
CSS to be in the app.
And then the other
one, I want to be
able to do this live reload.
I want it to be just
running off of my machine.
So if I show you a
scenario here-- you
need to see the actual thing.
So here we've got two
applications, one on the left,
which is just a static build.
And then we've got
another one on the right,
which is my live server.
And all things willing and
the network playing nice,
this will work.
Yeah, there we go.
So all I have to do
is just hit Save.
And that will go and update
itself on the other side.
There we go.
Now the really nice
thing with this
is it's surprisingly
simple just to get set up.
You don't have to do anything.
You are essentially defining
this product flavor,
and then you're
switching out the URL.
There's nothing
else beyond that.
And the nice thing
with the static
build is that when
I come to say,
I want you to build me
a brand-new project.
Down the bottom, there's just
these small couple of tasks.
And basically,
what we've got here
is this little beautiful
piece of code here.
It's basically saying,
when Android Studio goes,
I'm going to build
your Android app now.
Is there anything you want
me to do before I do that?
It will say, well,
actually, I want
you to copy my web application.
And then before it does that,
what you can actually say
is, well, before you
copy my web application,
could you actually maybe build
it and run it with Grunt?
And essentially, that's what
these two steps here are doing.
And they're really
simple little tasks
that just say, Grunt, build.
It goes and performs that task.
And afterwards, it will
copy it over and give you
a brand-new build
of your application.
So for me, this was an insanely
useful workflow because I've
seen a number of
Cordova applications
and the workflow with the
command-line interface
where you kind of just say,
Cordova, build or run Android.
And it does an entire
compilation step.
So then once you
start combining this
with DevTools, which
I'm going to need
to plug my phone in
for-- there we go.
So the minute I
plug in my device,
you notice that
in Chrome Inspect,
we start seeing my device
turn up with these two blocks.
Now basically, what this
application is doing
is displaying
WebView side by side
because the
performance is better
for horizontal scrolling.
But what's really nice is as I
start scrolling my device left
and right, you'll notice that
the blocks very helpfully
start moving backwards
and forwards as well.
So a nice thing with
this is now not only
are you getting exactly the
same experience that you'd
get on Desktop, but you are
getting the full features.
So there's the
office example that I
could do where I can sit
there and edit slides.
But the main thing that I think
is slightly more impressive
is if I go in here and
start saying FPS meter.
And you can start
seeing there that we're
getting a similar sort
of thing that we're
used to across varying
browsers-- well,
for Chrome DevTools,
should I say--
which is insanely powerful.
But what's even more impressive
is as I start going through,
and I start wanting to
combine different features,
you'll realize that
DevTools actually
starts becoming much,
much more useful.
This whole build step
process-- it still
works with the old WebView.
There's no difference.
The main thing is you can't
get live reload, because
of the lack of web sockets.
So the way that I can get round
that is by basically saying,
I'm going to add
a refresh button,
exactly the same that I would
do with basically swapping out
the URLs.
So yeah.
There is no DevTools support.
Unfortunately, the old WebView
is still going to exist.
And it's still not
going to have DevTools.
How many of you have heard
of Weinre, of interest?
Surprisingly, a large
number of hands.
I feel sorry for you all.
It is a very, very simple way of
basically debugging in browsers
that don't have
remote debugging.
You can get it through MPM
and just add in a script.
It's not ideal, but it does
give you at least something.
And then there's JSHybugger.
Now, if you're using
Cordova application,
this is basically you can
just have a plug-in that
will give you
access to DevTools.
And basically what
it does is it rigs up
the older WebView in
Android and basically
makes it appear
in Chrome Inspect
and works with the
Chrome DevTools.
So you start getting a
wider support of features
that Weinre doesn't have.
So we have our live
reload, which is awesome.
So the next step is
going to be, well,
how do I start adding features
into my web application?
Oh, useful.
So there's two main methods when
it comes to using the WebView
and integrating native features.
If you want to inject
JavaScript into the WebView,
there's this method,
evaluateJavascript.
And that's just
basically the same
as what you'd do if you
were in a normal browser
and you put JavaScript, colon,
inject or whatever you will.
To get stuff out of the
WebView, so from JavaScript
to call out into native
code, you have this method,
addJavascriptInterface.
Now, the way this
works is you have
something similar
to this method here.
Basically,
addJavascriptInterface
takes two methods, this
NotificationBindObject,
which is something
that I've written.
And it's a really bare-bones
JavaScript object.
And I'll show you
it in a minute.
And this name,
NotificationInterface--
and it's this name that you
will use from JavaScript
to access it.
So if I go into
DevTools for my device,
I can-- let's start again.
Stop it.
So if I go
window.NotificationInterface,
this is where it's been injected
into the WebView itself.
And this is how the
JavaScript would access it.
So it's just a plain
old object, and you
don't get any more
information than that.
Now if I go into the
NotificationBindObject,
you notice there's no
extending, no inheritance.
But the important part is this
method here, showNotification,
and the annotation just above
it, @JavascriptInterface.
Now the reason for that
annotation is basically to say,
I want JavaScript to be
able to call this method.
It came in for Jelly Bean MR2.
Essentially, you have
to be a bit mindful.
Because before that,
technically JavaScript
could call random methods
you're not intending it to.
So this method,
showNotification,
takes a string and a message.
And the main idea
behind this is--
if I get rid of my beautiful FPS
meter-- so the idea with this
is that when I hit this Show
Notification button, which you
can just about see, you'll
notice there's a little Chrome
icon that's just
appeared up in the top.
And it just says,
Chrome Dev Summit.
You're awesome.
So the really nice thing with
what we're got in DevTools
is I don't actually have
to have the JavaScript be
executing these native methods.
I can do it directly from here.
And there is the
new notification.
Now, that's a really nice way
of working because if you've
got essentially one part
of your team building
the native component, and
you're focusing on the website.
And they can kind of
turn around and go, hey,
I've just done this.
This is cool.
Can you check this out?
You don't need to be
worrying about whether you've
got a script to run this.
You can basically just sit
there and do it there and then
from DevTools.
The only thing you need
is the WebView running.
Covered it.
In terms of the old WebView--
I keep on clicking this.
In terms of the
old WebView, there
is no evaluateJavascript method.
So you have to use
loadUrl, JavaScript, colon.
The main reason you'd want to
use evaluateJavascript rather
than the old method in the new
WebView, it's actually faster.
Because basically, the WebView
is expecting JavaScript.
It's going to parse it
slightly differently.
Kind of think of
it as a fast path.
And the other one is
obviously-- the minute
you start using native features,
it needs to be pointed out,
the fact that you're
going to be running
on different
versions of Android.
Stuff comes and goes.
So you just need to
be aware of that.
Android Studio is
very good at just
pointing these
kind of things out.
As well as that, there's
also WebView samples
that I've just put a link
down at the bottom for.
And that has examples
of doing all of this
as well as shimming out
the loading of JavaScript,
et cetera.
So we have a workflow where
we've got live reload working.
And we have access
to native features,
and we have access to DevTools.
So now we've got
a nice environment
where I can sit and
code in my text editor.
I can then debug
it with DevTools,
and it's quite a nice flow.
We've got similar to what
we'd have on Desktop.
So the next step
is, what should we
be concerned about when
it comes to design?
Generally, each native
platform, one way or the other,
is going to have a set
of native components.
And generally, they range
from the small things,
like check box buttons, to the
much larger composite views.
And for me, the biggest
risk with web apps
is generally that they fall
into that uncanny valley
approach of, well, I'm going
to imitate the native platform
because that's where I'm living.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And generally, I kind
of go down the route of,
if you want to have native
components or native look
and feel, then try and
use the native components.
And don't imitate them.
If you can't use the
native components,
then do something different.
Even if it's something
similar, just
don't try and copy
it straight out.
Try and do the fact that
the reason you're using it
is because it's a nice UX.
Generally, the main
things that I point out
that I think web
apps are generally
going to use-- action
bar as well as tabs.
And realistically,
it's dead simple
to actually add this
for Android and iOS.
You can imagine a
simple case where
you can have something
similar on both platforms.
The view pager--
this is essentially
a way of having full-screen
views either side
and then swipe
from left to right.
That's I was using
in DevTools where
I had the images moving
in Chrome Inspect.
And then the other common
one is navigation drawer.
If any of you have checked out
Paul Lewis's weight tracker,
he's got a similar thing.
And the main reason
I point this out is I
think the Android team
have spent a lot of time
ensuring that certain
paradigms are met with this.
You'd be surprised the
number of different versions
of the same thing exist.
So who here kind of
feels like just creating
a button on the web
is nice and easy,
and there shouldn't really be
any kind of thought behind it?
Everyone?
So one of the
common things I tend
to find when it
comes to this is when
I start touching
these buttons, I just
start getting this weird blue
state that comes up over it.
So this one at the
top is an anchor tag.
The one at the bottom
is just a HTML button.
I get this weird orange
online on the bottom one.
And I see this come up
time and time again.
And to be honest,
depending on the design,
it can either kind of blend in.
Or it just really stands out.
So I'm going to
change these buttons.
So to get rid of this
blue tap highlight color,
the main thing you need is
webkit-tap-highlight-color.
Hit Save.
And then if I want to get rid
of the orange outline as well,
we just need to set
outline to zero.
Go on, update.
So-- ah.
I know why.
All right.
This time, live reload.
Go.
So it's just two simple things.
But now you can see
that the state just-- it
just does nothing, which
is exactly what we want.
From that, you just need to
do-- no-state-button, active.
So the key here is
just the active state.
Set background color.
We're going to go for blue.
So come on.
Oh, of course.
Yep.
So Grunt should be
taking care of SAS.
There we go.
So we've got state.
Now who thinks we're done?
Who can say what's missing?
Anyone?
So the trick here is if I go and
touch this button and hold it,
I get that beautiful
little nugget.
Now, I won't say you should
blanket disable user select,
because there's a
number of cases,
like if that was a phone number,
copy and paste is kind of cool.
It's a text button that I really
wouldn't want that to be there.
So the simple fix for
that is user-select, none.
So when that
updates, there we go.
Nothing.
Now I don't know about you
guys, but that kind of makes
me a bit sad, the
fact that I have
to disable one prefix
thing, one outline,
and then implement something
completely different
and then also handle the fact
that I don't want the user
to copy and paste it
to basically match
a native button.
But at the same time,
it kind of sounds
a bit laborious to pay this
amount of minute detail
to something.
But you do it once.
You're there.
You're good.
And you only do it
for the components
that you have in your web app.
And ultimately,
I want frameworks
to start just basically
implementing exactly this kind
of same thing because
it's essentially really,
really small little
nuggets of things
that I see a number
of developers do.
And it's quite a simple fix.
And the other thing that I
kind of wanted to talk about
was to kind of
reinforce this notion
of not trying to imitate native.
We've all seen web trends.
It's kind of one
of the great things
about the web in general.
If someone comes up with
this beautiful design,
and then we start seeing other
designers be inspired by it
and producing similar kind
of things-- and for me,
native apps don't move in terms
of trends as fast as the web.
So why try and imitate native?
Why not just keep this
going but actually bring it
to native platforms?
For me, this is what I
want to see web apps do,
take the things that
work and make sense
and then bring them into mobile
apps and show native apps
the kind of things that
the web is great at.
So that's kind of what
I wanted to talk about,
was this notion of having
a nice build process
where you can have live reload.
You don't have to
sit in Android Studio
and constantly
keep on compiling.
You can have native features
using the injectJavascript as
well as addJavascriptInterface.
And then we've kind
of covered design.
And for me, it's one of things
that from those three things,
it should be simple
enough to actually get
going something that didn't
exist with the old WebView.
You couldn't do this.
So if you go away from
this talk not really
remembering any of
this talk, there's
two things that I want
you to really remember.
The first one is this uses-sdk
android targetSdkVersion
equals 19.
Now the reason for this
is 19 is Android KitKat.
And if you set it to
anything lower than 19,
you've basically put the WebView
into a compatibility mode.
So to avoid any of
the web applications
from breaking from
Jelly Bean to KitKat,
we emulated some behavior that
existed in the old WebView,
so things like
target density DPI.
It's been dead for a
very, very long time.
But there are
still apps using it
and kind of relying
on it for their UI.
So to rip it out would mean
breaking a load of apps.
Unfortunately, though, if
you are following everything,
this can still have
adverse effects
if it's lingering around.
You start seeing
differences between the two.
So make sure you add
targetSdkVersion 19.
The other thing is
you will want to do
this
setWebContentsDebuggingEnabled
to true.
The main reason for this is
if you don't call this method,
you won't have access to
DevTools in the WebView.
It's basically it.
You don't have to leave it on.
You can basically
switch this on and off
depending on whether it's
a debug build of your app
or whether it's a release build.
But one way or another, when
you're first starting out,
you're going to
want to use this.
So in terms of what the future
looks like for the WebView,
the old WebView is still
going to be important
one way or the other.
It's still the
predominant version,
like Jelly Bean is the
predominant version of Android
devices.
So unfortunately, you still
have to kind of support it,
unless you're happy to go
for KitKat onwards, which
I wouldn't blame you if you did.
And I think at the
moment, updates
are still tied to Android
releases with the new WebView.
And generally,
everyone in the team
wants this to move
to auto-updating.
We kind of see it as
kind of the one thing
that we really want to change.
We just need to
figure out how we're
going to do it because
basically the WebView is
part of the Android framework.
And nothing, at the
moment, changes itself.
So we're trying to figure
out how we can do it.
And the other thing is
the Chrome Apps team--
we're actually bringing in a
lot of the Chrome Apps APIs
to Cordova as plug-ins.
So it'll be
interesting to see what
happens with the usage of that.
If you've got a
Chrome app already
that you're relying on native
features that are coming in
through Chrome Apps API, you can
now start getting it on mobile.
So there are three talks
I'd say go and check out--
perfmatters, which
is Tom and Nat.
They'll be covering things that
basically should help you write
60 frames per second
apps for the WebView.
Paul Kinlan will
be covering best UX
patterns for the mobile web.
And that's generally
just the things
that you should be
thinking about when
you're developing
mobile web apps.
And then Joe Marini is
going to be covering
develop Chrome apps
for desktop and mobile.
So thank you, everyone.
I've got a set of links,
Chrome docs, Android docs,
some samples.
And if you've got a web
application already out there,
there's a migration
doc which basically
covers a lot of the
common gotchas when you're
moving from the old
WebView to the new one.
So yeah.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]